das war ein Bilderrätsel ich habe es
vielleicht nicht ganz perfekt
hingekriegt aber das ist ein kleiner
Hinweis auf unseren nächsten Gast man
kann natürlich auch oben den Titel
dieses Videos lesen okay fail also er
kommt zu uns flying Uwe aus Hamburg und
das ist der Mann der auf Youtube ja
zeigt wo der Hammer hängt bzw hier der
Dampfhammer aber ansonsten in Realität
ist er glaube ich ein super friedlicher
aber eben wahnsinnig gut
durchtrainierter und das heißt natürlich
wie wieder Fragen überfragen und zwar
von euch von mir natürlich auch aber von
euch eben auch die nutzerfragen am
besten als Video hochladen den Infotext
Lesen am besten nur eine Frage und was
noch was fehlt was fehlt kreativ sein
genau ich drück die
Daumen